[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur lcp l'émission on
parle cuisine politique mais aussi
alimentation agriculture et écologie est
avec moi pour présenter cette émission
jean-pierre montanay bonjour jean pierre
bonjour brigitte pour jour emmanuelle
wargon bonjour emmanuelle wargon vous
êtes ministre délégué chargé du logement
anciennement secrétaire d'état à la
transition écologique vous êtes appelé
au gouvernement en 2018 tout vous
pourrez dessiner pourtant à faire de la
politique fille de lionel stoléru
ministre sous giscard et mitterrand vous
avez fait entre autres vos classes à
sciences po et l'ena passer par la cour
des comptes ou le cabinet de martin
hirsch vous êtes qu'on appelle une haute
fonctionnaire sans oublier un passage
dans le privé chez danone mais pas de
yaourt au menu du jour jardon au
contraire en baisse c'est l'air des
restos d'autoroute avec des tagliatelles
au saumon mais ici pour vous madame la
ministre en version gastro s'il vous
plaît avec des tomates séchées en
dessert une surprise du chef
à base de pommes et de cannelle dans les
pieds dans le plat nous verrons que le
gouvernement n'ait 2 milliards pour
étendre le dispositif ma prime reno pour
la rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
ça vous fait du pain sur la planche
espérez vous retirez tous les marrons du
feu et dans le dos ou des plats comment
concilier écologie et logement les
jardins partagés se multiplient près des
logements sociaux
comment les encourager allez on passe à
table tout de suite cuisine et
confidences
[Musique]
alors pas très difficile à madame la
ministre lorsqu'on vous demande votre
plat préféré vous répondez comme dans
une vieille pub culte un des pâtes des
pâtes
j'irai pas plus loin mais oui des pâtes
à quoi alors on a échappé aux pâtes au
beurre du menu enfant et on a réussi à
vous faire avouer qu'avec un peu de
saumon et ça serait bienvenu et qu'avec
des petites tomates séchées ce serait l
extase vos voeux sont donc exaucer vos
pâtes sont servis mais finalement avec
vous j'ai bien compris peu importe la
garniture
ce qui compte c'est la pasta c'est ça
vous avez du sang italien pour être si
dépendante accro aux pattes
non j'ai pas de sang italien j'ai du
sang roumains mais c'est vrai que j'ai
toujours eu un tropisme italien j'ai
appris l'italien au collège c'était ma
deuxième langue et c'était quand même un
choix un peu inutile au sens où c'est
pas la langue qui servent le plus dans
les relations internationales
mais j'ai toujours été attiré par
l'italie j'y vais souvent et puis j'ai
choisi des tagliatelles au saumon parce
que c'est une plaisanterie familiale en
fait quand j'ai commencé à travailler
avec les enfants qui sont arrivés moi je
travaillais beaucoup mon mari aussi on
essayait quand même de recevoir des
copains et donc j'avais quelques
recettes faciles parce que les
tagliatelles aux ce moment c'est un
avantage c'est que ça se fait en dix
minutes vous avez un paquet de
tagliatelles du saumon du saumon fumé
vous mélangez tout avec votre côté
éternel et izia ou d'autres effets
beaucoup de tagliatelles au saumon parce
que en fait c'est difficile de concilier
une vie professionnelle
une vie de couple une vie avec des
enfants et donc c'est vrai que la
cuisine j'allais quand même à des
basiques et au bout d'un certain temps
c'était devenu la plaisanterie et que la
famille ou les copains on vient mais tu
vas pas nous refaire de tagliatelles au
saumon et du coup pendant dix ans les
tagliatelles aux saumons ont été bannis
à la maison parce qu'on avait atteint le
seuil de 30 places mais c'est vrai que
les pattes c'est bon tout le temps c'est
bon avec tous ces bons avec toutes les
garnitures et puis c'est festif ça se
partager un petit côté le soleil de
l'italie arrive à la maison donc c'est
sympa
alors on va aller goûter vous allez nous
dire si elle ressemble à celle que vous
avez plus qu elles seront sûrement
d'ailleurs ce que je faisais un cuisiner
un peu moins maintenant
donc là on a des morceaux de son monde
c'est du cdu c'est du saumon par ac
n'est pas du saumon fumé 1
on a des tomates séchées en plus mais il
ya aussi avec si vous voulez à dos au
monde du slam au filet de saumon qui a
été sans doute pocher mais ensuite du
regard brigitte du du saumon fumé et
dernier vous aviez demandé
emmanuelle wargon aussi des copeaux de
parmesan parce que je crois vous mettez
des copeaux de partout sur les pattes
alors là est ce que le chef a pas osé
mélanger fromage et son agent voit sa
sauce du tour et croire qu'ils oui je
suis addict du copeaux de parmesan
bonjour mais surtout sur carpaccio
évidemment salade césar mais en gros à
peu près tous les plats de la maison la
touche finale avec des copeaux de
parmesan ça fait beaucoup rire mes
enfants en fait je suis plutôt gourmande
et donc j'aime bien notamment le salé et
c'est vrai je trouve que ça donne là
aussi une petite touche ensoleillée
agréable et même hérité du poisson
pardon même quand et du poisson des
coquillages vous mêlez le fromage que
c'est un peu ça se fait maintenant
mais pendant un temps on ne savait
jamais sur une table dans un resto
italien du fromage dont les pattes et
avec des ingrédients le dans les restos
italiens chic et que je demande du
parmesan en général d'abord je le
demande en italien mais mal et ensuite
le serveur ne me regarde
vaureilles parmigiano père travaux et
donc le serveur me regarde du genre son
accent et quand même pourri et par
ailleurs elle va pas nous demander du
parmesan sur un plaque est un plat
sophistiqué donc en fait j'ai tout faux
mais c'est pas grave
sinon il ya d'autres parce que vous
cuisiner à la maison et d'autres
recettes autour de la pasta alors je
fais beaucoup de lasagnes en fait et
donc que c'est souvent le dimanche soir
parfois pendant la période du
confinement mais même en dehors j'essaye
de cuisine et le dimanche soir pour un
plaqué le plat du dimanche soir simple
et puis après il en reste un peu dans la
semaine et c'est sympa et donc je fais
souvent des lasagnes souvent des
lasagnes végétariennes dans lesquels
j'essaye de mettre plus de légumes que
deux pattes parce que tout ça c'est
sympathique
mais j'ai une petite tape dans cette
voie là à grossir si je fais pas
attention donc j'essaye d'équilibré avec
votre tropisme italien j'imagine que
vous êtes très sensible de la cuisson
des pâtes ce qu'on appelle al dente vous
les aimez al dente vous les faites elle
est réussie c'est surtout quand vous
faites pour ne pas les faire cuire 7
minutes de trop qui gâche tout chez les
italiens sont très à cheval attire
d'abord le temps de cuisson sur le
paquet par jour faut il attendre à venir
donc voilà à bannir et du coup en gros
je reste à côté de la casserole et vous
je vous traite par rapport au temps de
cuisson qui a indiqué voulait laisser
généralement une minute de un peu plus
en jambes et moi un peu plus mais je
dois pas être là puristes du al dente
oui à trop pâle bente c'est un peu dur
mais également en général moi je les
fais plutôt qu à moins que sur le paquet
pour qu'elle soit effectivement pas
troquer si on mange pas des patchs et
vous qu'est ce qu'on mange et d'autres
plats signature maurice vraiment autre
chose que des féculents
non j'ai fait beaucoup de gigot beaucoup
de rôti beaucoup de curry on avait eu
une période dans laquelle je faisais
d'écurie et des tas de trucs dedans
la maintenance et les enfants qui ont
pris le relais il faut reconnaître
qu'ils sont meilleurs que moi donc
qu'ils se sont remis aux plats familiaux
ils font des chili fondé boeuf
bourguignon ou voire du bord succès eux
qui cuisine parce que vous avez trop de
travail vous n'êtes pas là donc ils ont
pris les fours mais voilà j'ai trois
enfants dont deux qui sont grands et
c'est vrai que les deux grands se sont
pris en main et donc le week-end pour la
semaine ils font souvent ces plats assez
généreux à partager je vois si de la
blanquette une fois de temps en temps et
vous la nouvelle on les retrouve dans
l'assiette parce qu'il est un grand pays
de gastronomie mais on peut très bien
manger en roumanie il ya des des très
bonnes recettes typiques et plutôt la
cuisine juive ashkénaze qui vient de
roumanie ou de pologne
alors on la retrouve pendant les fêtes
où on va avoir du bouillon avec des
boulettes de pain azyme s'appelle
détails de leur on va trouver aussi des
choses du genre à rang
harang haché fois haché et puis après
dans les desserts et donc c'est pour ça
que tout ce qui est pomme cannelle me
parle beaucoup parce que c'est des ser
là ils sont souvent à base de pommes et
de cannelle ça peut être des gâteaux ça
peut être des compotes n'y a pas une
influence cela aussi ou et balkanique
priorité c'est la seule à la roumanie la
pologne c'est la cuisine d'europe de la
france trouvera ça évidemment dans le
dessert vous avez faire le marché le
dimanche vous aimez ça choisir vos
produits sur les étals
oui j'essaye de j'essaye de continuer à
mener une vie normale le week-end ce qui
m'amène au supermarché tous les samedis
au marché tous les dimanches ou à peu
près et c'est vrai que j'aime bien le
marché le dimanche
d'abord parce que forcément à force je
connais tous les commerçants dont causé
aussi sympathique de discuter et puis
parce que ça permet aussi d'avoir des
idées de recettes de choisir des
produits de saison j'aime bien les
circuits courts et puis ça permet de
choisir du fromage qui est quand même un
des grands plaisirs dans l'existence le
fromage et le fromage et du marché et
hop et donc à chaque fois on repart avec
le petit chèvre qu'on n'a pas encore
goûté ou la tomme de moitié brebis moins
cher si bon italien les fromages n'ont
pas forcément italien donné des
consignes au ministère quand vous êtes
arrivé sur certains plats certains choix
d'abord on a mis en place le lundi vers
au ministère depuis que je suis arrivé
c'est à dire une fois par semaine en
l'occurrence le lundi on a des repas
sans viande et sans poisson une
végétation est devenu végétarien au
tinal exactement et au début ça les a un
peu sur reed désorienté parce que la
cuisine deux ministères si on leur dit
bah vous pouvez perdre ni viande ni
poisson sa limite et donc là aussi se
sont mis à des risottos ad la zac il
doit donc au quinoa et c est finalement
ça marche bien et donc c'est bien passé
du coup ça fait partie des choses qu'on
fait alors on voit que vous y connaissez
quand même pas mal on va passer au quiz
dans cette émission là alors avec votre
tropisme italien je pense que vous allez
trouver mais on va quand même vous posez
la question laquelle de ces propositions
vous pouvez le voir sur cet écran madame
la ministre
laquelle de ces propositions n'est pas
un nom de pâtes italiennes a pas kerry
je sais pas si j'ai le bon accent b dit
i say in volpini des fusils bukatif
fouzi listes et des pattes ils volent
tiny aussi après entre le 1er et le 2ème
city je crois que c'est plutôt de la
friture je dirais que cette victime je
suis pas sûr à 100% je suis content j'ai
piéger une ministre qui est un tropisme
italiens les pâtes les in volpini ils
sont plutôt des roulades non mais des
petites qui lamelles de peur voilà on
peut mettre un peu du spec et de fromage
ou des désirs volti ni d'aubergines on
fait cuire des tranches d'aubergines et
on omet un peu le pied de grue est
tombée facilement alors 2e couiza
présent dans lequel de ses desserts n'y
at il pas de cannelle à baklava turc b -
labié libanais ces carottes quelques
indiens des canaux lee sicilien ça c'est
pour vous jure comme quiz parce que si
vous vous rendez dans ces pays où serais
je dirais le cas rod cake indien alors
non non alors c b moha lavier libanais
le moulin biais libanais qui est une
espèce de flan et c'est à la fleur
d'oranger noter sa tâche et n'y a donc
pas de km bon alors je revienne
on apprend des choses à la hd je disais
en faisant votre portrait au début de
cette émission vous êtes la fille de
lionel stoléru j'imagine qu'à table chez
vous on parlait politique non le
dimanche ou autre c'est à dire pas très
très engagé on a toujours beaucoup parlé
politique à table bien sûr avec mon père
et ma mère quand j'étais plus jeune et
puis on a recommencé à parler politique
à table avec mon mari et la famille de
mon mari ma part que ce n'était pas la
même politique
ce mes parents c'était plus calme plus
tranquille et c'était plutôt du
partage d'informations en réalité sur ce
que l'actualité de ce que faisait mon
père c'est mon mari avec mes beaux
parents c'était vraiment de l'engueulade
politique avec des gens très engagé mes
beaux parents étaient communistes
on n'était pas tous d'accord puis
c'était une famille très vivante assez
bruyante dans laquelle il fallait
vraiment haussé la voix pour avoir une
chance de s'exprimer à vous imposez vous
à au début j'ai eu du mal et puis après
j'ai pris le pli et donc ils les
engueulades vous êtes vous n'êtes jamais
d'accord avec votre mari on n'est pas
toujours d'accord avec mon mari surtout
quand on commence à parler de la gestion
hospitalière de la tarification à
l'activité concessions elle est pas mal
la parole dans le débat et puis et puis
maintenant il ya les enfants qui eux
m'interpelle sur l'égalité des droits à
l'égalité des chances des luttes contre
les discriminations etc
ils sont à ses militants donc ça donne
des discussions animées de plus de
sujets polémiques qu'avant vous sentez
que c'est plus compliqué de parler
politique aujourd'hui c'est plus
fragmenté qu'avant où c'était un peu
binaire finalement avant on était de
droite ou de gauche on avait deux camps
à table maintenant aujourd'hui c'est un
peu éparpillé non je ne sais pas si
c'est ça avec la défense de certaines
idéologies de certaines idées là
l'écologie je pense surtout que pendant
une période assez longue les gens à
arrêter de parler politique à table en
famille ou entre amis et que finalement
la politique était devenu une espèce
d'univers plus personne ne pensait que
ça servait à quoi que ce soit de parler
de politique finalement il y avait des
fondamentaux et les choses étaient comme
elle était pouvait pas changer je trouve
qu'au contraire depuis quelques années
la politique est revenu que ce soit par
l'écologie ou par d'autres sujets et
qu'il ya deux nouveaux du débat
politique peut-être qu'il est plus
fragmenté mais surtout il est revenu
après une période où en fait c'était un
peu c'était plus trop le sujet quoi il
s'était plutôt l'impuissance de la
politique
et vous vous avez toujours voulu faire
de la politique en fait vous êtes tombé
dans la marmite quand vous étiez tout
petit alors moi j'ai toujours été très
intéressé par la chose publique et donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
décidé d'être aux fonctionnaires et j'ai
été membre de cabinet jusqu'à diriger le
cabinet de martin hirsch
mais c'est assez récent de passer de
l'autre côté c'est à dire de décider de
faire de la politique moi même
d'incarner de me battre pour mes idées
et c'est en fait assez différent plus
différents que ce que je pensais quand
j'étais de l'autre côté il ya une vraie
différence de fond entre piloter une
administration mettre en oeuvre une
politique publique
que appliquer une orientation et faire
en sorte que ça se passe bien et être
dans le combat politique
choisir des idées un camp les exprimer
les défendre et obtenir des décisions et
ensuite piloté leur mise en réseau
puissance dont on parlait avant
l'impression finalement faire de la
politique ça changeait pas la vie des
gens aujourd'hui vous vous rendez compte
que c'est difficile de faire changer les
choses de faire bouger une
administration un mois je me suis engagé
parce que je pense qu'il faut que la
politique puisse changer la vie des gens
et je voulais participer à cette
démonstration là que la politique ait
pas impuissante que l façade et constat
qu'on fait tous les enjeux écologiques
les enjeux sociaux la lutte contre les
inégalités les difficultés dans la
société française
en fait si on veut on peut contribuer ça
veut pas forcément dire qu'on peut tout
régler mais on peut faire une différence
après c'est difficile ça je le savais
déjà c'est difficile entre le moment où
décide et le moment où la réalité a
vraiment changé c'est vrai dans toutes
les politiques
c'est particulièrement vrai dans
l'écologie et dans le logement parce que
les changements ça prend du temps c'est
dans des changements le long terme
logement quand vous décidez de
construire plus de logements par dan et
ses plaisirs l'administration donc ça
reste difficile mais en revanche le côté
tout se vaut ou le côté il n'y a pas de
solution ou le côté tous pareils ou le
côté impossible
ça s'est vraiment fait ça m'indigne
c'est à dire je pense que c'est ça c'est
le jeu des extrêmes et donc si on ne
veut pas laisser le pays aux extrêmes
alors il faut montrer que si c'est
possible
alors c'est que en france et notamment
en politique le repas une place très
importante et qu'il s'y passe souvent
beaucoup de choses alors c'est la brève
de comptoir
alors on vous a demandé mme annuelle
variant de réfléchir à un souvenir
politique autour d'un repas est ce qu'il
y en a un qui vous est revenu plus
particulièrement en fait j'ai pensé à un
repas après un grand débat avec le
président de la république parce que
vous l'avez vous organisez un peu les
grands débats avec sébastien lecornu
voilà avec sébastien lecornu on était en
binôme
c'était y'a pas si longtemps mais on a
l'impression que c'était il ya très
longtemps en réalité pas ce qu'il s'est
passé tellement de
11 et donc on a organisé ces grands
débats et le premier a été organisée
dans l'eure dans une commune s'appelle
grand bourgtheroulde avec beaucoup
d'élus locaux
et il avait commencé en milieu d'après
midi
et c'est la première fois qu'on a vu ce
que ça voulait dire un grand débat avec
le président de la république à savoir
vous commencé vers 16 heures et à 19
heures être que l'on se dit bah voilà 19
heures on va savoir un peu ça va bien
finir par se terminer
pas du tout le président avait pris 40
de prise de parole
il avait écouté 42 personnes il avait
ses 42 notes et il a répondu aux
quarante deux personnes qui parlaient et
donc évidemment ça s'est terminé assez
tard ça s'est terminé vers 22 heures
et là on se dit mais qu'est ce qu'on
fait ou est ce qu'on peut aller dîner
quelque part alors on était au milieu du
département de l'eure et à 22 heures il
n'y a pas grand chose d'ouvert et donc
finalement sébastien des corps nus qui
était président du conseil départemental
est toujours évidemment très implantés
localement a fini par appeler un copain
restaurateur à vernon en lui disant
qu'ils y arrivent
est ce que je sais le président
j'ai bientôt fini mon service est-ce que
tu peut encore nourrir 20 personnes oui
si vous n'êtes pas trop difficile
t'inquiète on arrive à 20 et là le
cortège arrive chez le restaurateur à
qui sébastien n'avait pas dit qu'ils
venaient en fait et du coup il alors
qu'il finissait il était quasiment en
train de fermer et ben il a réouvert il
nous a sorti des entrecôtes et des
salades et c'était absolument super
c'était un repas sympa parce que c'était
aussi la première fois qu'on faisait cet
exercice et et finalement ça avait
permis de relouer de renouer pardon le
lien avec les élus douche donc j'ai se
souvenir du dîner un peu improvisée de
réouverture et ça tombait pas que ce
soit le président n'avait pas dit il lui
non ok le tati la fin quand il a vu
emmanuel macron ya peu passé par toutes
les couleurs de l'arc en ciel
mais c'est bien car on entrecôte oms
pression quand même voilà et au moins ça
lui a évité le stress oui c'est sûr
allez on va parler politique maintenant
et on va mettre les pieds dans le plat
dans les pieds dans le plat le président
a annoncé un couvre-feu entre 21h et 6h
du matin dans huit métropoles dont
l'ile-de-france pour freiner la
propagation d'épidémies
il va durer au moins quatre semaines le
chef de l'état a aussi encouragé les
français à se réunir à 6 maximum pour
stopper le virus qui se propage dans les
soirées privées
un report des élections régionales est
envisagée le plan de relance prévoit 100
milliards d'euros vous nous direz quel
est la part consacrée ou réservés au
logement et à quoi va être utilisé tout
cet argent
le dispositif phare c'est ma prime
rénove le gouvernement y consacrent 2
milliards d'euros
vous n'y verrez à caussade marie
bénédicte allaire nous a rejoint sur ce
plateau bonjour marie bénédicte the
majority qu'à rtl et tristan kino
maupoil bonjour tristan vous êtes
journaliste au figaro on met les pieds
dans le plat emmanuelle wargon alors si
on impose un couvre-feu maintenant dans
huit métropoles entre 21h et 6h du matin
est ce que c'est parce que les français
ont fait n'importe quoi depuis quelques
semaines
ou est ce que c'est parce que le
gouvernement a échoué finalement est ce
que la politique des tests n'est pas en
cause comme à saigner l'un ni l'autre
c'est simplement que c'est un virus
qu'on connaît pas c'est une épidémie qui
est complètement inédite et face à ça au
fur et à mesure des mesures d'ajustement
et des mesures barrières on regarde si
ça suffit ou pas là on a une progression
du nombre de cas qui est trop importante
notamment dans ces métropoles et donc on
a besoin de continuer à restreindre on
le fait au plus juste en essayant au
maximum d'éviter des mesures très
générale type confinement même leur
confinement locales et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons choisi ce
couvre-feu qui permet de maintenir
l'essentiel de la liberté d'aller
lire et qui c'est vrai pose une
restriction le soir mais qui va nous
permettre j'espère de passer la période
alors ce couvre-feu ça va poser un
problème particulier aux personnes qui
sont sans domicile fixe comment ça se
passe dans les centres d'hébergement
d'abord est-ce qu'ils sont très
fortement touchée par le copil
alors d'abord j'ai réuni ce matin en
visioconférence toutes les grandes
associations de
lutte contre l'exclusion et qui gère des
centres d'hébergement justement pour
avoir tout de suite la discussion avec
la fondation abbé pierre avec la phase
avec la croix rouge etc pour savoir
comment est ce qu il voit les choses
il y a le virus circule partout donc y
compris dans les centres pour en avoir
visité encore la semaine dernière en
fait les taux de circulation du virus
dans les centres d'hébergement sont pas
tellement plus élevé qu'ailleurs
donc on n'a pas de kloster spécifique on
a pas d'inquiétudes spécifiques en
revanche en période de couvre-feu qu'on
a besoin de mettre encore plus à l'abri
que ce qu'on est en capacité de faire en
temps normal et donc nous avons discuté
avec les associations de comment est-ce
que nous allons pouvoir gérer au mieux
l'ouverture de places supplémentaires ce
qu'on fait habituellement dans son
projet agit flocons bien fait là si en
plus sûr ah bon on va le faire à la
demande c'est à dire qu'avec les préfets
on va chaque semaine regarder les
besoins notamment les besoins non
couverts par les samu sociaux les
centres d'appels pour voir comment
est-ce qu'on peut ouvrir plus de place
et là notre objectif c'est d'ouvrir des
places plutôt individuelle parce que
sous il nous arrive d'ouvrir des places
dans des gymnases par exemple pour de la
mise à l'abri mais ça résout pas
complètement le problème si vous mettez
dans une seule pièce
énormément de personnes donc ouvrir plus
de place ensuite permettre aux
travailleurs sociaux aux salariés de ces
associations aux bénévoles de ces
associations de pouvoir continuer à agir
pour les plus vulnérables y compris en
période de couvre feu ce qui veut dire
gérer la question des attestations des
dérogations pour qu'il y ait pas
d'ambiguïté et puis bien sûr faire
attention à ne pas verbaliser les
personnes qui sont sans domicile fixe
s'est pas du tout c'est pas du tout
l'objet c'est pas du tout l'idée donc on
est tout de suite en train de travailler
dès maintenant dès ce matin à comment
est-ce qu'on n'augmente encore notre
rêve
notre capacité à répondre aux besoins
dans cette période alors les français
sont invités à rester davantage chez eux
le président républicain dick fait lé
télétravail est beaucoup plus l'hiver
arrive
on sait que rester chez soi ça engendre
des coûts supplémentaires y compris pour
les foyers les plus les plus modestes
est ce qu'il ya des aides qui sont qui
sont prévues justement pour
pour accompagner les foyers les plus les
plus en difficulté alors d'abord vous
avez entendu le président de la
république annoncé qu'il y aura une aide
exceptionnelle pour les bénéficiaires du
rsa et des aides au logement hauteur de
100 euros + 150 euros par enfant donc
c'est 150 euros plus 100 euros par
enfant pardon et ça ça permet de
soulager le budget des familles les plus
modestes
après on a constaté pendant le
confinement qu'en fait les factures
d'énergie était pas tellement différente
en période de confinement et en dehors
ce qui est pas normal puisque
normalement quand vous êtes chez vous
vous devriez chauffer plus et consommer
plus d'énergie ce qui veut dire aussi
que ont continué à chauffer et qu'on
régule pas bien des appartements ou les
maisons quand on est au travail
donc ça veut dire qu'on peut progresser
sur la régulation jour nuit par exemple
et puis après de toute façon ça rejoint
l'une des grandes actions du plan de
relance dont vous parliez tout à l'heure
ma prime rénove lorsque nous souhaitons
aider les français à faire des travaux
d'amélioration de la qualité de leur
logement sur la rénovation énergétique
thermique justement pour isoler mieux et
baisser les factures et là on aide très
fortement les ménages les plus modestes
puisque là on est jusqu'à 90 % de la
facture totale des travaux et ça se
retrouve après sur les factures
mensuelles bien sûr puisque en général
on divise par deux voire plus comme
actuellement ses robes elle est bien
élargi maintenant et elle va concerner
tous les publics non oui ma prime rénove
concernés depuis le 1er janvier la
moitié des français les plus modestes
laon louvre à tous les français mais on
est plus ceux qui ont moins on a
toujours un taux dead qui va être autour
de 80 90 % pour les ménages les plus
modestes pour les ménages les plus aisés
l'aide sera plutôt autour de 30 à 40% et
c'est normal il n'y a pas besoin de
financer à 90% les travaux des ménages
les plus riches et bien elle wargon
puisqu'on est à table
c'est la question qui s'impose les
grands perdants de ce couvre feu sont
les restaurateurs à 21h il ya plus de
services on aurait pu décaler à 23h ces
deux services qui leur permettrait
peut-être de rentrer dans leur coût est
ce que ces deux heures
tu es vraiment crucial d'un point de vue
sanitaire je crois qu'il faut qu'on soit
d'abord guidé par la situation sanitaire
et quand on voit l'alertent des médecins
hospitaliers des réanimateurs en fait de
tout le système de santé on se dit qu'il
faut vraiment faire attention et donc
l'idée c'est quand même de limiter les
contacts sociaux les interactions
sociales dans la mesure du possible les
restaurants pourront pour ceux qui le
choisiront le pourrons garder un service
public pas face à va dépendre ça va
dépendre de chaque situation de comment
fonctionne chaque restaurant et après
évidemment notre responsabilité c'est de
les soutenir financièrement donc chômage
partiel maximum aide du fonds de
solidarité donc au fait il y aura un
financement pour le manque à gagner des
restaurateurs mais notre objectif c'est
vraiment de ne pas nous retrouver dans
trois semaines ou dans un mois avec une
saturation des services de réanimation
et ces voix là la tension commence à
arriver
du coup est ce qu'on pourrait imaginer
d'inciter les employeurs a terminé la
journée de travail
un peu plus tôt justement pour que les
gens aient le temps de rentrer chez eux
et d'aller au restaurant peut-être un
peu plus tôt que ce qu'ils font voilà
notamment pourquoi ni de france je crois
que chacun s'adaptera je sais pas si on
a plutôt envie d'étaler les heures de
départ et d'ailleurs c'est pas
incompatible puisque l'idée c'est quand
même que tout le monde se retrouve pas
dans les transports en commun exactement
à la même heure il ya eu pas mal de
flexibilité notamment en ile de france
mais pas que pour que les heures de
départ et d'arrivée puisse être avec une
amplitude plus grande
on peut imaginer que certains jours on
commence plus tôt on repart plus tôt et
donc si on le souhaite on peut aller au
restaurant
d'autres jours on est décalé dans
l'autre sens c'est vrai que ça perturbe
nos habitudes de vie ce sont des
contraintes supplémentaires il
on n'est pas 100% libre de faire
exactement ce qu'on souhaite faire comme
d'habitude mais on est dans une
situation inédite avec un virus qui
continue à tuer avec en réa maintenant
la moitié des patients qui ont moins de
65 ans donc ça veut dire que ça touche
toutes les catégories de la population
et puis une épidémie qui monte trop vite
donc c'est la responsabilité du
président du gouvernement que de réagir
face à cette progression des chiffres de
contamination
quelles conséquences ça pour
l'organisation d'une ville on pense
évidemment aux bureaux d'affaires qui
sont aujourd'hui délaissée et est-ce
qu'il faut la repenser la ville comment
voyez les choses
est-ce que ça des conséquences
économiques sur des quartiers la défense
évidemment ça a des conséquences de très
court terme bien sûr mais vous avez
raison
en fait les deux crises que nous avons
vécu la crise des gilet jaune d'abord et
la crise du coc vide aujourd'hui sont
deux raisons de repenser l'aménagement
des villes et des périphéries des villes
en fait de tout le territoire français
en période de qu'ovide il faut qu'on
trouve plus de flexibilité pour éviter
que l'activité et enfin le mode de vie
principales pour ceux qui travaillent
dans des bureaux soit un temps de
transport long entre la maison le bureau
et puis massivement au bureau et retour
et donc le télétravail va prendre de la
place
évidemment en ce moment avec une
incitation à télétravailler mais même à
la sortie de la crise il me semble que
le télétravail va devenir quelque chose
de qui sera dans nos habitudes de
travail un jour par semaine pas
forcément tout le temps et donc ça veut
dire que quand on aménage une ville
quand on aménage des nouveaux quartiers
moi je crois vraiment à la mixité en
fait à deux types de mixité ce qu'on
appelle la mixité fonctionnelle désolé
du côté un peu techno mais c'est à dire
par un quartier que de bureau ou pas un
quartier que de logements ou pas que un
centre commercial
mais un quartier mélangés dans lequel on
trouve les fondamentaux et dans les
fondamentaux probablement un lieu de
télé travail collectif
parce que quand on sera sorti de la
période de contamination je pense que
nous aurons peut-être envie que working
d'aller travailler dans ce que l'on
appelle le coworking ou ce qu'on appelle
aussi des tiers lieux qui sont des lieux
dans lesquels on peut venir travailler
boire un café rencontrer des gens
exemple avoir besoin
c'est un quart d'heure ou une heure de
travail ont invité la halle et dans ces
espaces de coworking que l'on connaît
qui sont payants mais généralement est
ce que les entreprises pourraient offrir
aux employés la possibilité de s'y
rendre
alors pour l'instant quand on incite au
télétravail c'est plutôt pour pas
rencontré trop de gens au moment où on
travaille donc c'est plutôt pour rester
chez soi donc pour l'instant on est en
période de qu'ovide de limitation des
contacts sociaux
mais quand on sera sorti de la période
de contamination je pense que ce corps
king de proximité a du sens et pourrait
être financé par les entreprises on
pourrait très bien imaginer que les
entreprises qui aujourd'hui paye à des
mètres carrés de bureaux et un petit peu
moins de mètres carrés de bureaux par
salarié d'un côté et permettent à chaque
salarié de se rendre gratuitement dans
un lieu de cover king de proximité donc
ça se trouve que c'est un modèle qui
peut vraiment être intéressant mais qui
est plutôt pour après la crise ce que
les 700 milliards pardon la crise et 100
milliards d'euros
finalement quelle part dans ces 100
milliards seront consacrés au bâtiment
au logement c'est que quand le bâtiment
va tout va c'est aussi des emplois
derrière c'est une reprise de l'économie
alors quel pari sera consacré à l'or
dans le plan de relance donc dans les
100 milliards il ya 30 milliards pour
l'écologie et il ya 7 milliards et demi
pour le logement donc c'est quand même
une part vraiment importantes là dedans
il y a beaucoup pour la rénovation tout
type de rénovations les maisons et les
appartements des particuliers mais aussi
les bâtiments publics parce qu'on a
quand même des écoles des commissariats
et c'est qu'ils auraient bien besoin
qu'on les rénove et aussi les logements
sociaux avec une enveloppe pour que les
bailleurs sociaux continuent à rénover
les hlm
et puis après il y à de l'aide à la
construction soit pour continuer à
construire dans des endroits dans
lesquels il ya vraiment besoin aux zones
tendues en essayant de garder de la
densité de la densité qui peut se
compenser aussi par des espaces verts
mais de la densité parce que il ya des
tas de régions dans lesquelles le se
loger est devenu quasiment impossible la
plus en fait de garde pas assez d'offres
de scapa terrain pour construire et puis
parfois on construit un peu bas c'est à
dire les documents d'urbanisme sont très
largement concertée donc les
villes les agglomérations passe du temps
à définir quelle est la bonne manière
d'organiser l'espace
et puis 10 à tel endroit on peut
construire des immeubles de quatre ou
cinq étages puis finalement au moment de
signer le permis de construire on se dit
que finalement trois étages c'est
peut-être suffisant mais si on fait ça à
tous les endroits où on pourrait mettre
quatre ou cinq étages ça veut dire qu'on
répond pas aux besoins de logement il
vaut mieux y répondre ce qui permet
d'avoir d'autres endroits dans
l'agglomération ont fait des jardins
partagés où on retrouve de la nature
donc on a besoin de garder cet équilibre
et puis après il faut qu'on urbanistes
sur ce qu'on appelle les friches
c'est à dire ces endroits un peu
délaissé qui sont un peu du no man's
land c'est à dire ça a été un site
industriel mais l'industriel est parti
qu'elle arrêtait déjà un bâtiment dans
lequel il y avait une activité mais le
bâtiment est vide ça a été une zone
commerciale mais en fait elle en est
réduite à une voie de chemin de fer ça a
été une emprise autoroutières ou
routière parce qu'à un moment on a pensé
qu'on allait tendre telle route l
autoroute et puis finalement on l'a pas
fait et c'est par celle qui en fait sont
un peu dans un espèce de vide celle là
elles sont déjà urbanisées et donc quand
on construit là on préserve de la
ressource naturelle aïe ça prend quand
même énormément de temps entre le moment
où on a le projet ont fait les démarches
administratives
on peut installer des personnes dedans
alors la construction c'est toujours
long après moi j'ai souhaité qu'on
travaille sur les délais parce que on a
des procédures a simplifié à
dématérialiser des autorisations à
donner le cap irrite sur les permis de
construire c'est aussi une discussion
avec les élus locaux puisque les permis
de construire ce sont les maires qui les
délivre donc on a aussi besoin de
relancer une forme de mobilisation pour
cette construction neuve et puis enfin
un jeu rebouc juste sur votre question
on peut transformer des bureaux en
logements est dans une période dans
laquelle il va y avoir peut-être moins
besoin de bureaux on peut encore
simplifiée et le modèle économique de la
transformation de bureaux en logements
devient plus favorable
j'étais à toulouse il ya quelques jours
et j'ai vu un vieil immeuble de bureaux
qui a été transformé en logements
étudiants et franchement ça marche très
très bien
il y avait des contraintes
architecturales l'architecte a trouvé
une manière de d'aménager quand même le
bâtiment les loyers sont vraiment assez
raisonnable pour des logements étudiants
et c'est chouette
est-ce que vous pensez que
vie moyenne qui était victime jusqu'à
maintenant de la métropolisation peuvent
se réveiller on voit des articles sur le
sujet ce que vous y croyez ce que c'est
quelque chose je pense que la réflexion
qu'on a à voir sur l'aménagement un fait
elle touche toutes les échelles du
territoire elle touche les grandes
villes comment est ce qu'on les fait
évoluer
elle touche les villes moyennes comment
on capitalise sur le fait qu'elles sont
en train de redevenir attractive et elle
touche même la ruralité parce qu on a
aussi des gens qui sont très contents de
se réinstaller dans des bourgs qui sont
vraiment plus petit et sur ses villes
moyennes
c'est pour ça je vous parlais du
mouvement des gilet jaune parce qu'en
fait je pense qu'il faut qu'on entende
les deux messages ils sont
complémentaires
c'était aussi des personnes qui sont
dans des zones résidentielles plutôt
cheap lotissement dans lesquelles il ya
très peu de services ya plus qu il n'y a
pas de commerce il n'y a pas d'accès aux
transports en commun
finalement il ya une forme d'isolement
et donc comment est-ce qu'on lutte
contre cet isolement en reconnectant ces
lotissements au coeur des villes
moyennes soit avec plus de transport y
compris d'ailleurs avec des pistes
cyclables complètement sécurisé comment
faire revenir des services des commerces
mais aussi des lieux de convivialité
partagée c'est pour ça que le corps
working peut s'insérer dans cette
logique donc comment est-ce qu'on recrée
du lien social pas seulement à l'échelle
des métropoles mais aussi à l'échelle
des villes moyennes et de la banlieue
des villes moyennes ça se pense que
c'est vraiment une question pour les
années qui viennent et on peut et puis
il se passe beaucoup de choses en france
en fait là tu donc on va aussi montrer
toutes les expériences intéressantes une
excuse a vu passer sept cette offre de
une chambre de 6 mètres 50 à paris pour
134 mille euros oui je l'évitement
quelle est votre réaction
et ma réaction c'est qu'elle est
probablement illégale en fait déjà
puisqu'il ya un texte en tous les cas
définis la naissance à la dette publique
elle a été publiée nous on a contacté la
plateforme en demandant des explications
elle est probablement illégale parce
qu'elle est en dessous de 9 m² est
normalement c'est le minimum d'un décret
qui définit la levée pour un local sans
que ce soit
pour dormir finalement oui mais enfin
c'est pas comme ça qu'elle était
présentée noël et vendre leur âme en
allait de la vente la wii c'est à la
vente mais n'a pas le droit de vendre me
dois de louer ces six là c'est parce
entend 4000 euros par mois ces 134 mille
euros c'est le prix c'est un achat mais
en tout cas là on a le droit on l est en
deçà des standards raisonnable de
comment est-ce qu'il faut habiter et par
ailleurs le prix est dingue donc oui moi
je trouve ça extrêmement choquant ça
veut dire ça c'est pour ça que moi je
suis favorable à l'encadrement des
loyers même si c'est un dispositif pas
très facile à mettre en place parce que
la valeur locative et la valeur de vente
les deux sont liés la valeur de marché
elle est aussi lié à l'anticipation que
vous pouvez avoir de ce que peut
rapporter un appartement une maison si
vous voulez allouer donc les deux sujets
sont liés et c'est vrai qu'on atteint on
atteint des choses qui sont aberrantes
mais là on peut légiférer latule l'état
semble impuissant finalement aura pas on
va pas légiférer sur un prix de vente
maximum au mètre carré
c'est pour ça que si on légifère sur ce
qu'est la décence d'un logement
notamment location ça donne déjà une
indication
et après ça nous ramène au point
précédent il faut plus d'offres il faut
construire plus parce que c'est parce
que les marchés sont extrêmement tendues
c'est à dire qu'il ya pour une offre
énormément de demandes que ça fait
monter la crise une commune peut faire
baisser l'immobilier
c'est aussi un débat une question
aujourd'hui que tout verdon pour
l'instant ce qu'on constate c'est dans
l'ancien un nombre de transactions donc
de vente qui a un peu baissé et qui sera
probablement semblable à ce qui s'est
passé en 2018 donc ce sera plus bac 2010
9 ans retrouvera le niveau 2018 donc ça
ne s'est pas effondré et des prix qui se
sont stabilisés en particulier dans les
zones les plus tendues type paris intra
muros et qui continue à augmenter
légèrement en province il n'ya pas
d'anticipations d'un effondrement après
si ça permet au marché de se calmer je
pense que dans ces zones très tendues
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
et dans le secteur du logement social
l'état décidé dans le projet de loi de
finances 2009 interne fonctionne et un
milliard d'euros sur action logement ce
qui émeut beaucoup les acteurs du
secteur est ce que ça va apporter un
coup
à la construction de logements sociaux
justement non je ne crois pas parce que
action logement est dans une situation
dans laquelle pour des raisons aussi lié
à la crise et donc de retards dans un
certain nombre de projets la trésorerie
est très élevé la trésorerie d'action
logement elle est autour de 9 milliards
d'euros donc on a décidé un prélèvement
exceptionnel qui vient financer les
aides au logement qui elles mêmes vont
augmenter parce qu'en période de crise
comme les revenus baissent les aides au
logement vont augmenter d'autant plus
qu'on valait calculée sur les douze
derniers mois et pas sur l'année deux
ans auparavant
après ça laisse de la marge à action
logement pour continuer à jouer son rôle
et au contraire moi je souhaite que
action logement reste un partenaire fort
paritaire pour ce que c'est important
que ça reste gérée par les partenaires
sociaux et qui soutiennent le logement
social et les priorités collectives de
la politique du logement et même après
un prélèvement d'un milliard
je pense que c'est tout à fait possible
on a besoin de continuer à construire du
logement social notre objectif c'est
110000 agrément cette année de logement
social il sera difficile à tenir
c'est pas sûr qu'on y arrivera parce que
les permis de construire ont pris du
retard c'est normal les les communes à
cause du confinement d'abord puisque
beaucoup de services en moins tourné que
d'habitude c'est tout à fait normal à
cause des élections municipales elle se
sont étalées sur quatre mois donc il ya
forcément quand vous n'avez pas
d'exécutif municipal ou quand vous êtes
en train de gérer un cri la règle tout
est forcément un peu ralenti donc ce
n'est pas une mise en cause des
collectivités c'est juste le constat que
c'est fait et du coup on aura
probablement du mal à faire les cent dix
mille logements sociaux cette année mais
où continuent et ils sont financés
on sait que vous êtes intéressé par le
val de marne notamment pour les
élections régionales une liste
départementale là
on voit que ziad crise sanitaire ce
couvre-feu on sait pas exactement pour
combien de temps on est embarqué
là-dedans finalement est-ce que vous
pensez que la question des élections
départementales et régionales doit se
poser d'un report de ces élections
en tout cas je pense que ça sera inédit
de faire une campagne de faire
complètement campagne dans une période
de restriction de autorisation de
manifestation publique donc pense que
c'est je pense que ça a du sens de
laisser la question ouverte le temps
qu'on voit comment la situation
sanitaire évolué parce que pour les
municipales la campagne avait eu lieu
avant le confinement bien sûr le
confinement est intervenu entre le
premier et le deuxième tour et donc la
campagne s'est terminée en période de
crise mais elle avait très largement eu
lieu avant là ça supposerait de faire
une campagne complète dans cette période
de circulation forte du virus dont je
pense que se dire que la question est
ouverte et qu'il faut peser avantages et
inconvénients avant de décider me paraît
assez sain parce que si on dit fils
histoire de quelques mois a battu façon
il n'y a pas de décision qui est prise
du tout parce qu'il ya plutôt une
interrogation collective
à mon avis c'est assez trans partisan
quand même c est ce qu on peut faire
vivre la démocratie dans une période où
ce sera difficile de se rassembler est
ce qu'on imagine que ce sera plus facile
de se rassembler dans la période prévue
de la campagne c'était dire en gros
premier trimestre de l'année prochaine
je pense que c'est une question qui
mérite d'être posée après voilà ce sera
une décision collective
le président a quand même souligné hier
qu'on en avait pour jusqu'à l'été
prochain donc c'est un peu répondre à la
question au final et trancher tout
dessus presque pas le président a dit
que le virus allait continuer à circuler
au moins jusqu'à l'été prochain
personne ne sait avec quelle intensité
on a vécu poste confinement l'été
dernier avec en fait assez peu de
restrictions l'inde à des restrictions
plus forte
difficile de dire combien de temps elles
vont durer là pour l'instant elles sont
prévues pour 4 semaines pour les
métropoles quatre à six semaines avec
une réévaluation
c'est aussi une question politique
sensible donc je pense que on a besoin
d'une concertation politique sur ce
sujet et donc il ya une commission qui a
été annoncé et je pense que c'est bien
c'est que voilà ce soit à une discussion
sur la base des mêmes informations pour
tous et qu'ensuite on puisse trancher au
bouquet
la gestion de crise juste de valérie
pécresse du coc vide et dans la région
ile de france et ce qu'elle gère bien
les choses pour moi la gestion de crise
elle est à l'échelle de l'état d'un côté
et des communes de l'autre donc les
régions peuvent être en soutien sur la
partie développement économique mais
c'est pas la région qui à la manoeuvre
sur la gestion de crise même si madame
pécresse a fait un certain nombre de
sorties sur le sujet merci en tout cas
marie bénédicte allaire d'avoir partagé
ces instants avec no mercy tristan qui
nommé poil alors le temps presse on va
bientôt passer au dessert mais avant
cela la troisième partie de cette
émission c'est le dessous des plats
alors signe des temps emmanuelle wargon
plus en plus de jardins potagers
fleurissent au milieu des villes comme à
paris notamment dans les quartiers
populaires
exemple au coeur du 20e arrondissement
avec des citadins qui cuisinent leurs
propres légumes qu'ils récoltent mêmes
qu'ils fabriquent du compost c'est un
reportage de rabbi cas et nathalie
gloire ce petit marron qui s'apprête à
finir en soupe
monique l'a vu grandir c'est agréable de
pouvoir
dégustez les choses que l'on a produit
soi même on les a vus en graine on les a
soignés jusqu'à ce qu'ils deviennent
matures
pourtant cette retraitée de 73 ans
n'habite pas dans une maison avec jardin
vous mesdames ses légumes elle les fait
pousser dans ce potager au pied de son
logement social en plein coeur du 20e
arrondissement de paris fait les
dernières plantations qu'on peut faire
tu vois la berrière se retrouveront ça
va donner des souffleurs ça c'est des
choses qu'on peut planter en optant
c'est la fin de saison donc les tomates
on ne vont plus mûrir fois qu'on va les
cueillir son nez cueilli un certain
nombre je vais faire de la confiture
voilà dans ce potager de 200 ménages à
rire compost même été prévu alors
monique ne jette plus ses épluchures à
la poubelle elle les recycle ici il ya
c'est le premier bac on dépose ce qui
ensuite transformera en salle cette
partie là ont la réponse sur la terre et
c'est ce qui remplace en fait tous les
pesticides insecticides engrais plutôt
un sunnite
ici on plante pour le plaisir les
quelques dizaines de fruits et légumes
ne permettent pas de nourrir le quartier
mais ces potagers urbains répondre aux
besoins de citadins en mal de nature de
l'autre côté du jardin il y a aussi des
fleurs et ça c'est le domaine de
christine ça permet de retrouver comment
dire est la nature de se mettre en
accord avec elle ça maintient la forme
ça on fait d'activités on partage
voilà on rencontre beaucoup de gens
depuis quatre ans la verdure à remplacer
la dalle de béton alors ici on se prend
à rêver de la ville de demain lorsque
c'est en train de se monter petit à
petit ce que je disais toile arbres et
on constate que c'est
un désir les gens veulent ça
[Musique]
emmanuelle wargon vous venez de voir ce
reportage est ce que aujourd'hui les
programmes hlm devrait être
nécessairement penser avec des jardins
partagés avec de la verdure en tout cas
ce reportage c'est que du bonheur quand
même hein ça donne vraiment envie parce
que on voit bien tous les avantages que
ça se reconnecter à la nature c'est
aussi un du lien social parce que c'est
une activité partagée pouvoir manger ce
qu'on fait pousser ce qui est quand même
super donc je trouve que oui ces
expériences elles ont beaucoup de sens
alors après comment est ce qu'on les
généralises c'est vrai que ça va penser
il ya des réflexions à laguiole oui il
ya des réflexions à deux niveaux en fait
d'abord on réfléchit à dans les nouveaux
programmes hlm qu'on va lancer en fait
qu'elle est forcément chum durbridge h
et on pouvait soit le bouddha oui oui là
se trouve à deux niveaux hlm est en
général
côté programme hlm ont réfléchi à savoir
si on a envie de définir un peu le
logement hlm idéal de demain à la fois
dans sa construction elle même y compris
le fait par exemple que il ya
systématiquement un espace extérieur
balcon ou autre et puis ce qu'on peut
avoir en commun et un jardin en commun
je pense que c'est extrêmement important
et puis après plus globalement à
l'échelle de l'aménagement et
l'urbanisme
mais moi je suis convaincu qu'il faut
que nos grandes opérations d'aménagement
d'urbanisme
elle embarque systématiquement de la
nature et de la nature partager j'étais
donc à toulouse en début de semaine et
j'ai à la fois vu ce bâtiment de bureaux
qui est devenu des logements étudiants
et aussi signé une opération
partenariale avec la métropole de
toulouse pour l'aménagement d'un nouveau
quartier au dessus de la gare de
matabiau et dans ce nouveau quartier il
y aura quatre hectares de pleine terre
il y aura deux mille cinq cents
logements des bureaux et aussi des
hectares de pleine terre qui seront des
jardins et potentiellement des jardins
partagés
je pense qu'il faut qu'on est maintenant
le réflexe que dans nos opérations
d'envergure
il ya systématiquement non seulement de
la nature qui par ailleurs a aussi plein
d'autres avantages
il ôte fraîcheur quand il fait chaud
l'été mais de la nature partagé dans
laquelle chacun peut venir à part d'une
écurie tire elle aussi être exactement
parce que c'est à la fois de l'écologie
parce qu'on refait poussé en ville et du
lien social et c'est les deux qui sont
intéressantes parce que finalement on
peut pas nourrir à fait
une population non mais c'est pas avec
ça que vous nourrissez la totalité du
quartier c'est évident ces deux-là
points et ça va avec d'autres démarches
promouvoir des circuits courts quand on
a dit désormais dans les cantines
scolaires c'est au moins 50 % de bio et
circuits courts là c'est beaucoup plus
ça c'est beaucoup plus de volume c'est
beaucoup plus transformant pas ce que ça
veut dire que des milliers et des
milliers d'enfants mangent tous les
midis avec des circuits courts donc
aulas vous recréez de
l'approvisionnement c'est pas tant le
fait de nourrir la totalité de
l'immeuble qui est important c'est la
reconnexion à la nature mais emmanuelle
wargon est ce que j'avais déjà des
promoteurs qui propose clé-en-main déjà
des projets où ils ont intégré tout ça
dans notre reportage c'est au ces avec
une rénovation qu'on a enlevé cette
dalle en béton et qu'on a transformé en
potager est ce qu'aujourd'hui on vous
présente des projets où il ya une
station de compost desjardins un toit
terrasse qui est transformé quasiment
mini ferme urbaine
est-ce que ça les promoteurs les
promoteurs intègre dès le départ alors
maintenant de plus en plus on commence à
voir des projets de promoteurs dans
lesquelles il ya ce type d'aménagement
après il ya un truc intéressant qui sont
les projets participatifs
il ya un certain nombre de promoteurs
dans le logement social ou en dehors qui
font des projets en passant plus de
temps avec les personnes qui vont y
habiter ou un groupe témoin de personnes
susceptibles d'y habiter
j'ai visité un projet de ce type à côté
de bayonne est là en fait la conception
de l'immeuble a été fait avec les futurs
habitants et bah ils ont mis un
toit-terrasse partager avec un petit
barbecue et un jardin partagé en bas
parce que dès que vous demandez aux gens
comment est ce que j'imagine qu'ils vont
vivre et bien on arrive très vite à ces
choses là et après la question c'est la
rénovation parce que on construit un
pour cent du bâti en france chaque année
1 % on renouvelle 1%
donc c'est bien de s'occuper du 1 %
qu'on construit mais il faut s'occuper
des 99 autres pour cent donc à chaque
fois qu'on enlève une dalle et qu'on met
un jardin dans un site existant c'est
aussi celle de sang comme en ont fait la
ministre du logement géré ce paradoxe
qui est moins de bétonisation et en même
temps construire du logement
c'est presque c'est très paradoxal
finalement c'est la qualité en fait de
ce qu'on construit qui fait la
différence parce que vous pouvez avoir
un immeuble qui fait quatre cinq six
étages dans lequel vous avez chacun un
espace extérieur un toit-terrasse
partager un jardin en bas éventuellement
une buanderie communes etc
et donc sur le papier ça fait de la
densité mais en réalité à l'intérieur
vous avez à la fois de l'espace de la
lumière de l'espace extérieur et un
accès à la nature et si vous faites ça
vous pouvez avoir en face un parc urbain
la possibilité d'avoir une école dans le
quartier etc
donc c'est moins la maison individuelle
comme unique solution la maison
individuelle va rester une solution est
une aspiration document sel compriment
et jure de inventer d'autres modèles etc
ces modèles de qualité qui feront la
différence dans votre bureau vous dites
parfois je suis en train à mon petit
niveau mais d'inventer la ville de
demain et j'espère vivement cette ville
de demain vous la voyez mettons 2050 ce
qui nous laisse un peu de temps
comment vous l'imaginez en fait
j'imagine des villes des manières
d'habiter demain en fait parce que c'est
même pas la ville ou pas la ville c'est
la grande ville comment est ce qu'on y
habite probablement avec des immeubles
relativement haut mais beaucoup d
espaces verts et beaucoup de services et
puis après la périphérie les
lotissements peut-être avec un type
desjardins un peu plus petits pour
chacun des pavillons mais sur le terrain
qu'on a gagné ou sur le terrain
intercalaires entre l'entrée du
lotissement et le début de la ville des
lieux travail partagé des lieux de
proximité des commerces et retrouver un
lien social et puis après le centre
ville d'une ville qui est un peu
périclité dans laquelle les commerces
sont un peu tombés en déshérence et ya
beaucoup de rideaux fermés redonner de
la vie à cette ville en en rénovant
réhabilitant les immeubles actuels et
enfin à la campagne peut-être des
hameaux qui reprennent vie avec des
viennes ferme dans lesquels avaient
grâce à ma prime rénove on a tout
retaper donc j'imagine des manières de
vivre en france et je crois que l'une
des questions c'est la connexion entre
ces différents endroits c'est pour ça
que en fait c'est un sujet ministre du
logement bien sûr mais c'est un sujet la
dilce forme ville d'hirson forcené et
puis modèle l'activité économique est
aussi économie sociale et solidaire ça
qu'il faut mettre ensemble alors il nous
reste quelques minutes on passe au péché
mignon
alan avait compris que votre péché
mignon c'était la pomme et la cannelle
c'est votre cfrn roumaine et le chef
bien il a édifié ce petit dessert
formidable notre architecture alors je
vais vous dévoiler le libellé de cette
recette est une pomme royal gala bio
s'il vous plaît il ya confites cuite à
basse température sur un sablé breton à
la cannelle avec sa glace vanille mais
vous êtes ravi mais ça a l'air super
il ya une pomme il ya de la cannelle
c'est magnifique et on déguste
alors on va goûter leur on dirait mais
très très bon brigitte a raison on
dirait un do not c'est vrai beaucoup de
gestes parce que c'est de la pomme à la
place des trains baigner et en plus sa
pomme est tiède avec la glace super bon
pourquoi l'album et la cannelle vous en
fait souvent des desserts comme ça en
fait je fais assez souvent de la compote
deck l'hiver arrive je ne l'achète 3 kg
5 kg de pommes au marché et je fait
consciencieusement de la compote avec
juste de la pomme de la cannelle parfois
un peu de sucre mais à peine et c'est
pareil c'est un plat d'hiver face manche
tiède éventuellement avec des petits
gâteaux qu'on fait à côté est bon quand
l'hiver arrive et que c'est un peu
tristounet voilà la compo très chaud car
elle devient devient la base de
l'alimentation familial mais je n'ai pas
sophie ce terreau et le modem face à des
bretons c'est un veau d'enfance et puis
ma grand tante qui était né en roumanie
faisait des espèces de gâteaux à la
pomme on avait légèrement l'impression
que quelqu'un avait marché sur le gâteau
c'est à dire ce n'était pas ce n'était
pas rater il était il est s était pas un
gâteau tout lisse tout beau un gâteau de
pâtisserie c'était un espèce de truc
bizarre mais là c'est là la patte était
un peu acidulées la pomme à la cannelle
à l'intérieur et c'était juste super bon
donc ça me rappelle les goûter chez la
grand tante mine à vous laisser déguster
ce dessert qui a été réalisé comme le
plat d'ailleurs par chez françois ce
qu'est le restaurant qui nous a servi
aujourd'hui comme chaque semaine
d'ailleurs et qu'on remercie évidemment
chaleureusement
merci jean pierre emmanuel varin
à vous tous de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve évidemment la semaine prochaine
avec un autre éviter autour d'un plat et
d'un dessert très bonne suite de
programmes sur lcp
[Musique]